yeah he still has one but still I mean  this is yeah this he really wants to win  normally huh  and he's also down to 10 seconds yeah  he's he's also a bit nervous yeah  Queen C5  no Queen takes busy blunder  I mean he could have just taken on C5  and played rookie one that looked like a  draw yeah  and the Queen on C5 protects the f8  square  and queen from C1 protects the F4 Square  so Queen F7 checking H6  simply over here that's it wow  incredible yeah  unbillable unbelievable  yeah I mean that's that ending must be a  draw right like there is nothing really  yeah well just very quickly we are  jumping to  to Wesley's game wow we're gonna end up  in some  brutal Queen's queen queen ending yeah  very nice  very nice a never-ending Queen ending